so wait Kyle when you like got on set
for the first time and stuff like to
work how old were you 14. and so like do
you remember it was it like whoa or was
it like when yeah it was it it was kind
of
like there's few there's there's a
handful of times in your life when you
get to walk into something that is just
so new and so different and that you
have no
I had no concept of what I was doing
other than I could say lines and make
them sound real when I was young and
that's you know I didn't have any skill
sets I hadn't gone to class I hadn't
really studied or learned anything I was
just a kid who could talk I guess and
they liked me for it it just kind of
happened it sounds like this just kind
of happened yeah it did and then and
actually like that I was ever on where
people really took me under their wing
was Smallville
uh wow I was really really taken care of
on that set and people showed me the
camera and showed me around people were
very very good to me on that so how old
were you not actually being there yeah
how was the first
man I was my mom was still with me so I
wasn't old enough to be there by myself
so I had to be 15 16. oh and I was 30.
and you were 30. oh my God it's my
little brother and so how were people
nice on The Closer just kidding I'm just
kidding Kyle
um yeah I worked with your mom on the
clothesline okay so you he was 15 and
you were 30 and you were was it out here
in L.A no I was in Vancouver think oh
God okay and did you so you went with
your mom and you stayed at like a hotel
or an apartment or something something
Place Hotel I didn't know they put kids
there it's a little you know well wait a
minute because so see